each year microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world
including leading scientists renowned
experts in technology
book authors and leading academics and
makes videos of these lectures freely
available
good afternoon and welcome my name is
kirsten wiley and i'm here today to
introduce and welcome
daniel jurgen who is visiting us as part
of the microsoft research visiting
speaker series
daniel is here today to discuss his book
the quest
energy security and the remaking of the
modern world
it's actually on the new york times
bestseller list right now so we are very
lucky to have him
speaking at microsoft the world's
appetite for energy is growing
the absolute numbers are staggering
billions of people
are becoming part of the global economy
and as they do
their incomes and their use of energy go
up energy and its challenges
where it comes from who controls it how
it affects the planet
will continue to be a defining issue for
our future
daniel jurgen is a highly respected
authority on energy
international politics and economics he
received the pulitzer for his book the
prize
he is the chairman of ihs cambridge
energy research associates
and serves as cnbc's global energy
expert
please join me in welcoming him to
microsoft thank you
thank you everybody i'm very pleased to
be here and to be
uh part of this uh event and
uh to speak here under the auspices of
the microsoft research
visiting speakers session
and uh i've also actually want to
particularly acknowledge
curtis wong because he
when a previous book i'd done
in television series was called
commanding heights
and it was kind of right at the kind of
a transitional point in terms of
the web and so forth and uh continue to
be very grateful to you for what you did
in terms of driving to make sure that we
had a web presence and it's very
interesting
we had a very highly rated uh tv series
called commanding heights
but it didn't take very long for it
turned out that more people watched it
over the internet than over uh pbs and
so
as part of that transition and so i'm
glad you're here today to have the
chance to meet you
so where i'd like to start is uh not
with the
quest but the preced preceding energy
book i wrote which was called the prize
and a few days after saddam hussein
invaded kuwait i the prize went to press
with these
final words ours is a century in which
every facet of civilization has been
transformed by the modern and
mesmerizing alchemy of petroleum
ours truly remains the age of oil well
that was two decades ago
that was the 20th century we're now in
the 21st century
oil remains the world's most important
commodity
not only fueling modern society but in
terms of global economics and in terms
of global politics
but so much has changed in the world of
energy
in so many different ways uh and as i
found
is vividly evident to me writing the
prize writing the quest
first of all uh the soviet union no
longer exists
china which was only you know a few
words really in the prize because at
that time
china was just a minor oil exporter
is now such a dominant factor in the
world economy and world politics
and uh indeed china is the only country
that gets two chapters of its own
in the quest so many other things
happened climate change went from being
an issue off to the side to being a
major
uh not only energy issue but economic
and political issue
oil which was supposed to be twenty
dollars a barrel forever
went to 147.27
uh the us was going to import vast
amounts of liquefied natural gas
instead we have the shale gas revolution
which is changing the economics of the
entire
energy business and then on top of all
of that
uh just this year the dramatic and
tragic uh
accident at fukushima in japan in the
courses of the tsunami
and at the same time uh the arab spring
which uh
has as it unfolds has such implications
for energy
so there was a lot that happened uh that
uh
made it uh very appropriate to
try and make sense of the subject of
energy and that was the second thing i
really wanted to write
not just about oil but a right but right
about the whole spectrum of energy
uh natural gas electric power renewables
efficiency climate change and put it all
together in a narrative and a story
and so all of those factors came
together as i set out to
write this new book called the quest
now this this story is populated by a
host of very interesting characters some
of them
well known to everyone and some of them
not well known
and yet very influential and i thought
i'd just give you a flavor of them
many of them interestingly are
innovators researchers
scientists in one form or another and uh
one of the uh planet money on uh
on npr actually kind of talked about the
role of
the important role that geeks play in uh
in this particular story
to just give you uh some examples
there's a professor at caltech named ari
hagan smith
and uh he was a great uh expert on kind
of the chemistry of foods
uh he had figured out where the flavor
of onions and garlic and wine came from
he was a man who achieved immortal
status as identifying the active agent
in marijuana
and he was fascinated and obsessed with
trying to understand
the flavors and pineapple where that
where that sweet flavor came from
and he was researching that one day in
his lab at
caltech in pasadena when he walked
outside i suspect
to have a smoke and instead of the clear
beautiful
california weather which had helped to
bring him to california he
felt in his lungs what he called that
stinking cloud of of
smog and he said well
at that time there's a huge debate as to
what smog was and what caused it he said
i can figure this out
and he said he got it on the first
nickel and he identified the cause of it
he became known as the father of smog
which irritated him a great deal because
he said who is the mother of smog
but he then later when the california
air resources board was set up
which has now become kind of like almost
the regulator of the world automobile
industry
he was the first chairman appointed by
ronald reagan and he went on from
that to continue to do research on all
of this
and you could kind of draw a line from
when ari hagen smith walked out of his
lab in 1948
to the appearance of the electric car on
the road today
so that's one character uh in the book
another is a man named hader aliyev
probably not many will know if you know
his name
uh he was a kgb general he rose to the
top of the soviet union he was in the
pollock bureau
until he had a fight with mikhail
gorbachev and was exiled back to his
native azerbaijan looked like things
were over
soviet union collapses he emerges as uh
no longer a soviet man but a native son
the first native son president of
azerbaijan
and more than anybody else is
responsible for yoking central asia
and the caspian sea back into the world
economy where they had once been
somebody else who's important is a
young man you know we know many people
are graduating from university today
with very good degrees having trouble
finding jobs and this particular
individual also had trouble
finding a job uh he in fact was reduced
to tutoring sort of like
kaplan style and uh he
uh even even then dentist he actually
offered free samples of tutoring
trying to get business his father wrote
a letter to a chemistry professor and
said my son grows unhappier
day by day he feels that his career
has been permanently derailed
this young man was albert einstein he
then
found a job in the patent office in bern
in switzerland
it was not very taxing it was a very
slow
summer so over 10 weeks one summer in
you wrote five papers that changed the
world one of them was a paper on
photoelectricity
which is what he won the nobel prize and
that
became the basis of the solar industry
that we have today
it took 50 years from that paper to get
the first solar cells
up on satellites in competition with the
soviets
after sputnik was launched and here we
are now 106 years later
and solar is still kind of finding its
way so
one of the things it tells you is long
lead times in the energy business
um the um
i'll mention one of two other people i
think who are just of interesting
one is i i can assure you that this is
the only book ever written on
energy that will talk about the worst
moment in ronald reagan's career as an
actor
and that moment was uh when he couldn't
get work as an actor and was reduced to
doing stand-up comedy
fronting a singing group called the
continentals in las vegas
he came back to la thought his career
was finished phone rings
it's his agent on the phone says you
know ronnie i have a great new job for
you
and he goes to work as the spokesman for
general electric
now and there's a wonderful picture in
the book of reagan and his wife nancy
demonstrating this amazing
incredible new invention called a
portable radio and that was not that
long ago
but the reason i talk about him in the
book is because it's a way of talking
about the great shift that happened in
america when a society after world war
ii we got electrified
uh his you know nancy reagan talked to
one of the ads for general electric
about
this amazing new electric servant a
vacuum cleaner it was
really i mean all these things that we
now take for granted
and what unfolded in the u.s in the 50s
and into the 60s
is now what's unfolding in china and
other emerging markets
we had 10 or 11 annual growth
electricity now
they do and their struggles with that is
a part of
what is the current drama of world
energy i'll mention one last character
who also has his picture in the book a
man named jim delson
who spent new year's eve 1981
atop a wind turbine in a blizzard
in the tehachapi pass in california
trying to get his turbine up
by midnight because at midnight the tax
credits expired and so
the economics depended very highly on
this he thought there has to be a better
way to do this
and so he goes off to europe and
discovers it
goes to denmark and discovers that much
sturdier
wind turbines are made in denmark and
they are made
by companies that came out of this very
sturdy hearty
danish agricultural machinery industry
and he imports them and for a time
really the california wind industry in
california in the 1980s was the
epicenter
of the world wind industry were these
danish
wind turbines and so part of what i
tried to do in the book
is not only look to the future to the
kind of question you said about how we
supply a world of of
that will be eight and a half or nine
billion people with energy but also
how did things happen so i came to the
conclusion that the modern wind industry
not the wind industry that goes back to
persia and
and don quixote and everything but the
modern wind industry
really owes its existence to the to the
marriage
of the danish agricultural industry
agricultural machinery industry and
california tax policy
and it's out of that that we have the
modern wind industry
well these are some of the stories and
you know as i thought
as i was coming here and uh so many of
you involved in research
realize that this is really a uh
the role of the innovators of
technological
innovation of people seeing different
ways to do things being able to act upon
it is one of the main themes and stories
that runs through this book but there
are three big questions that
defined the story for me as i was
working on it over these past five years
one is we have a 65 trillion dollar
world economy
after the downturn and growth resumes
might be a
130 trillion dollar economy in 20 years
a couple decades
where does the energy come for that so
that was first question
second question was security energy
security both in its classic sense
disruptions concerns for instance about
you know we've had a civil war uh in
libya that has disrupted supplies
uh we've had disruptions before in the
middle east but also
new kind of disruptions and uh described
by the ceo of
sony after a attack on their website is
the bad new world of cyber vulnerable
vulnerability and that is a question for
the critical infrastructure of the
energy industry
and then the third question is uh how do
you put together
the world's need for energy with the
world's environmental objectives
and not a simple answer to that so all
of those together
uh formed the the three questions that i
kept knocking up against i kept running
into
as i was shaping my story
the big themes are one is geopolitics
which is just
always has been and always seems to be
part of the
energy business and it's this theme runs
throughout the book
geopolitics was a critical part of the
what people called the caspian derby
this
bracing competition for who was going to
have
the control of oil natural gas the
countries
after the breakup of the soviet union in
the arena of the caspian
and the uh central asia
uh i s certainly the geopolitics of
energy is
is fundamental in the relationship
between the united states
and china and that relationship overall
is so important
to the future of the world and certainly
to the future of the two countries
and uh energy and we can talk some more
about that
one way or the other iran's nuclear
program will have a major
impact on world energy markets
indeed we can see in so many different
ways now this
sort of sense of rising tension and the
tension between iran and saudi arabia
played out in syria played out in iraq
played out in bahrain
played out in yemen and add to that the
recent plot to assassinate the saudi
arabian ambassador at a restaurant in
washington d.c
that the us government traces back to
the iranian government
and hanging over all uh iran's nuclear
program so
those whole set of geopolitical issues
uh very much
will have a major impact on what happens
to energy
indeed also we've now passed beyond the
arab spring
and now it's a challenging work of
of reforming societies reforming
economies reforming
legitimacy of government but one thing
we do know
is that the that the that the
consequences of the arab spring upended
the strategic balance
which has underpinned uh these semi
stability in the middle east and thus
the stability of energy supplies
and we're still in the early stages to
see how the
new balance develops and that will be
have big implications for energy
now this geopolitics of energy is
accentuated by something
else a new demand for energy
demand for energy that's coming from
what used to be called the developing
world and today are called the emerging
markets
one way to express it and the term i
came up with to try and describe it
is the globalization of energy demand
that just like everything else gets
globalized so
has uh demand and to kind of give you a
sense of it just
show you how it's changing if we went
back to 2000
two-thirds of world oil demand was used
in the developed countries
north america western europe japan today
it's 50 50 between the developed
countries
developing emerging markets and it's
going to shift and the developing
countries are going to be using more
more oil and and that's going to be
accentuated by what we're going to have
in our country
which is a term that i use in the book
peak demand that is we've reached a
point where our oil demand is going to
go down
partly because everybody is going to be
driving more efficient cars
by 2025 they're supposed to get 54 miles
per gallon new cars
compared to 30 and also demographic
changes have occurred as well so
all of those things mean our demand is
actually going down
while it's going up on the other
direction
and you know the when you look at the
whole picture one thing
really stands out you won't be surprised
it's to use a real estate term
the build out of china you have 20
million people a year at least moving
from countryside
to city they need housing they need jobs
they need transportation and all of that
requires energy
and we can see it happening china
already uses more energy
total than the united states much of
that is coal
but increasing part of it will be uh oil
and it's growing demand for oil
it seems to be just locked in it's going
to continue to unfold
let me give you uh just something that
will make it very vividly clear
let's again go back to the year 2000 in
the united states in the united states
17 million new cars were sold
china less than two million were sold
okay now we go to 2010
china 17 million cars 11 million in the
united states
and it's thought that the chinese number
could go up to 25 million
or even more and so all of that will be
reflected in
in in oil needs now
uh some see an inevitable competition
for resources developing
i think it's very and you can see how
that could happen but i think it's very
important that it actually
not happen and that there be the
emphasis on the common interest between
the united states and china
as consumers interests and stable
markets and indeed
how interconnected the two countries are
let me turn to another theme
in the book which is technology
and and this really does get to the
questions of innovation the kind of
issues that many of you are very
involved with and it is so striking that
innovations that were dreams or theories
or
science experiments to use a term that
is used in
silicon valley in one decade a couple
decades later just become
part of the accepted uh
normal part of the energy world and we
see it again and again
one place that is unfolding is in what's
called shale gas
which is associated with that word that
has now become well-known fracking
is only in about 2008 that it became
evident that this was a major new
resource
yet it had been 25 years in development
but it burst on the scene in 2008
and in some ways it might even be
described as the biggest energy
innovation
of the last couple of decades at least
in terms of its scale
in terms of its impact it's 30 of our
natural gas production now
it's a number that is uh certainly going
to uh continue to go up
and it has um it's changing kind of the
whole economics of the energy sphere
it's affecting
the competitive position of everything
from nuclear to wind
now uh it's very interesting on
oil uh kind of the
familiar old energy resource one has
seen major innovations
and if you look at it in a hemispheric
way sort of
quite striking innovations actually
there are three that are kind of
changing
almost the map of world oil one and they
all are the result of breakthroughs
technological innovation and they're
basically
all things that are post uh 21st century
in terms of their real impact
one is what's called the oil sands in
canada which now
produces much oil as libya produced
exported before the civil war began
canada is by far now the largest source
of u.s oil imports and continuing to go
up
the second is what the brazilians call
pre-salt
which is uh it took incredible computing
power
and as the president of the state oil
company says
amazing algorithms to solve the problem
of identifying the oil that
rested beneath these very thick band of
salt
and brazil is now on its road to being a
powerhouse of world oil
by the end of this decade it could be
producing twice as much as venezuela
which has always been thought of as the
big
latin american oil country the third
change
is here homegrown in the united states
it's what's called tide oil or shale oil
it's the application of the same
technology that brought you
shale gas to oil and it has turned
north dakota into the fourth largest oil
producing state in the country
and also i checked last night the state
with the lowest unemployment rate
in the country and we're seeing that in
other parts of the country too
and so it's also this is also an area of
substantial growth and so
you now have an oil boom back in the
united states which people hadn't
expected to see again so that's
technology at work there
technology certainly at work in terms of
what i call
in the quest the rebirth of renewables
because you had the
kind of modern renewable industry began
in the 70s
early 80s then it entered what people in
the industry and some of you may know
people have been part of it called the
valley of death because uh
it was the economics turned so adversely
against it
price of oil collapsed no one seemed to
care and then
around 2000 it began to change was not
only for general environmental reasons
not only for security reasons but two
other factors came into play
one is climate change and concern about
climate change
moving from a minor issue to a major
issue and then the growth that i was
talking about before
in terms of the emerging markets and
suddenly seeing there was going to be
much more energy demand
and seen renewables as part of the
solution to that
so you had people come into the energy
business who were not there before
and in the chapter called the science
experiment uh in the quest i talk about
how venture capital found its way into
uh into the
energy business and i quote one of the
pioneers of venture capital in uh
renewable new energy
in fact one of the funders of tesla uh
the electric car
but he said in the 90s when he was
making this investment
his friends uh thought he was committing
career suicide that it was you know
all over but uh he stuck with it and
around 2004
silicon valley in general started to
move in it to it and you sort of
saw the kind of ecosystem of innovation
uh at work in the renewable sector that
you hadn't uh
hadn't really seen before so today
i think if you look at the green company
industries are actually
big businesses last year about a third
of the installed
capacity in dollar terms in electric
power around the world was uh
uh was actually renewable energy but
it's interesting that they're
big businesses but they're also small
when you compare them against the
overall scale
of the energy industry in its totality
and so
the need for the renewables is to
establish that they're competitive at
scale
and i think that's the kind of game
that's been played out right now
but you look at the wind business a wind
turbine today is a very different wind
turbine
than one in the 1980s that might produce
a hundred times more electricity so
an enormous amount of progress has been
made
and we see the progress in solar and the
name of the game there is just to drive
down calls drive down costs
we've also seen of course the migration
of a lot of manufacturing to china
because of the advantages that they have
in china in terms of
low-cost manufacturing but so
the view that i have in the book and i
think you'll find it's really the story
again where did solar come from where
did wind come from
is to try and understand the um
the dynamics and therefore kind of some
sense of the pacing
a change although always with the sense
that there
can innovations that can come and
surprise us and come from left field
and you know although it's now sort of
off the table i would certainly say
keep your eyes on what happens in terms
of biotech
and energy the other major theme
is environmental considerations and
as you know environmental considerations
are challenging the very notion of a
future based on fossil fuels
government policies are either looking
for low carbon sources like natural gas
or no carbon sources like
wind and solar and there too i got very
interested in the question
how did climate change go from being
this very peripheral question to being
such a dominating question
and i thought i was going to write just
one chapter on it i actually ended up
writing
six chapters on it because it was so
interesting
and i found myself starting actually the
story in the alps in the 1770s
and then in the 19th century finding
scientists
who you know it's kind of one thing
leads to another uh
around 18 the 1830s famous scientist
named louis agassi
kind of figured out that there had
actually been something called an ice
age that had proceeded the
current age and people were then too
fascinated with glaciers
and started saying if there'd been an
ice age how do we know
that another ice age isn't going to come
back and the glaciers are not going to
migrate down again
and destroy civilization and so
a lot of the climate research that was
the original climate research in 19th
century was about the fear of a return
of uh of of of glaciers
and one of the most famous scientists
arenas who
identified you know how carbon could
make the climate warmer
he was a swede um he was depressed by
those long dark
nights uh and the long dark winters and
he actually thought it would be great
uh if there was global warming because
uh it would make sweden a verdant
paradise of of crop growing
so but it was really only in the 1950s
and 1960s when again another key
scientist another key
tenacious obsessive individual
named keeling who had done his phd at
caltech went to scripps and began
measuring carbon that you start to see
the beginning of the consensus that now
drives climate policy just a couple of
other things on
other environmental considerations up
until march 10th one would have been
talking about a nuclear renaissance
because it seemed that everywhere around
the world you know chernobyl the
accident chernobyl was long forgotten
chancellor merkel the german chancellor
angela merkel was pushing for germany to
reverse its policy and commit to a
more important role for nuclear and its
future then came that terrible accident
at fukushima
and she led the change in germany to say
we're going to shut down our nuclear
industry by 2022 and we see instead of a
nuclear renaissance now we see a nuclear
patchwork
some countries going ahead china russia
some countries highly
undecided really japan is quite
undecided itself about what it wants to
do
in the united states the obama
administration has said that they
want to continue to pursue nuclear
because it's seen as the only
large-scale
carbon-free electricity and there are a
couple of projects that are
going ahead i would say that also
local pollution although not so much in
the developed countries in developing
countries
is certainly driving energy innovation
and nowhere of course more than china
where the air is is so difficult and so
painful to breathe and it
makes the smog of los angeles look mild
by comparison
and so in china a very strong drive for
cleaner energy technologies now
i kind of bring the story of the quest
together around two two subjects
one is what's called the fifth fuel
sometimes i.e
energy conservation or energy efficiency
i've always thought and i continue to
think it is actually the biggest
potential near-term supply that we have
uh and in fact when people say oh we've
made no progress in energy efficiency
that's actually not correct
as a country we're twice as energy
efficient today as we were in the 1970s
and the early 1980s
and it might be a legitimate reasonable
national strategy to try and double it
again
the problem is how do you make it vivid
and it was summarized for me
by the european union's energy
commissioner
when he was extolling the virtues of
efficiency and trying to promote it
but saying his problem about promoting
against renewables
is that you just don't have any good
photo ops for energy efficiency
or what he said is actually there's no
red ribbon to cut
and so i think that continues to be a
actually a an obstacle and yet the
impact of it can be enormous
now i didn't think when i was going to
when i started the book that i would
finish where i finished it but i
finished it on the question
of what kind of car you and everybody
watching will be driving in 10 or 20
years
is it indeed going to be an electric
vehicle
or is it going to be a highly efficient
internal combustion engine that gets 60
or 70 miles to the gallon
will it be hybrids uh
what's what's the mix going to be and
the truth is i don't think we know
certainly this arrival of the electric
car
is quite a major
development it takes it reconnects the
beginning of the
20th century with the beginning of the
21st century because we had there was a
race between the electric car
and the gasoline-powered car at the
beginning of the 20th century
indeed there's a wonderful picture in
the book of a painting of thomas edison
and henry ford
having dinner together where ford is uh
telling edison about his electric car
uh his not his electric car his
gasoline-powered car and uh edison says
you know that's a great idea and he
and he says that hydrocarbon that you
want to use that's a really good fuel
but then a couple of years later edison
180 degrees changes his mile doesn't
like the pollution
says we can do it with an electric
battery spends a lot of time and money
trying to get an electric car going
but ford comes out with the model t 895
dollars without the top
and lo and behold the race seems to be
over
and here we are 2011 looking into 2012
and the race has begun again there's a
great set of two pictures in the quest
one is of a
woman charging a car in 1910
and the other is the ceo of uh uh nissan
renault with their charging a leaf
uh in 2010 and it's sort of the pictures
i put them together because they almost
look like identical pictures
and sort of saying this race has begun
again but it's still very early stages
and i would think it would be four or
five years
before we have clarity about what kind
of scale is going to
be achieved and it will be something
that will obviously
have very broad ranging significance
now in writing the quest
i recognized that there will be
surprises
uh that there will be new developments
there are always
these quote surprises that come along
when everybody has a consensus and
agrees where things are going and it
goes in a different direction
and they may be technology they may come
out of labs
they may be politics they may be the
result of economics
we don't know there's by definition
they're surprises although
you can spend some time working with
scenarios and other things
to try and see what they might be but
even as these surprises occur and
changes occur
i hope that the quest will provide a
perspective
on how our energy world has become what
it is
uh how what our energy world may look
like in the future
and how to prepare for it
you know you come to the end of writing
a book and you've got to go back
and write two key parts one is the
introduction to set it all
out because you've learned a lot your
thinking has changed over the five years
you've worked on it
and you have to write the conclusion to
tie it together where do you want to
leave
people where do you want to leave
readers where is your thought at the end
of it
and i'd come across a quote by a man
named sadie carneau
engineers will know his name because of
the carnot cycle
describing how a steam engine works he
laid it out in 1824 in a paper
titled reflections on the motive power
of fire
he wrote that the invention of heat
engines
using what he called combustibles was
producing a great revolution
for humanity now carnot saudi carnot is
very interesting because he's not only a
scientist and engineer
he was also a soldier his father in fact
had been minister of war for napoleon
and he looked on the steam engine not
only from an engineer's point of view
but also from a soldier's point of view
from a geopolitics point of view
because he said that britain had bested
had defeated france partly because of
its mastery of energy technology
and he saw his mission was to teach the
french
about this technology to kind of write
the geopolitical balance
and i thought that is really interesting
because
you know even at that stage the
geopolitics was part of the energy
picture
but i as i looked at the
quest and i looked at the people i'd
written about and the developments i did
and how these stories unfolded
i concluded and you may rightly conclude
when you read the quest that indeed
a great revolution that phrase of
carnauba fairly describes
the entire process of innovation of
harnessing energy
that began in the 18th century and this
is clearly
a revolution uh that
will continue into the future and indeed
i conclude is that this
and it's why i conclude that this is a
quest this particular quest this
quest around energy is a quest that will
never end
and is a quest that never should end
thank you
would you like a little discussion for
sure
you mentioned increasing fuel economy
standard for cars now we've been there
before in the 70s they had fuel
efficiency
in the car so airfocus invented the
minivan then they have used uh
his standard for minivans and somebody
invented the suv within the truck
and do you think the program invents
some new name and get around it
a certain time well first of all you're
quite right and it's actually one of the
fascinating things i had was going back
saying where did the minivan come from
and it was kind of an odd idea that
chrysler had
and in the early 1990s on the basis of
its
progress with the minivan people called
chrysler the most successful
automobile company in the world and uh
indeed i talked to the former ceo of
general motors and he talked about how
general moto was trying to catch up with
minivans and
trying to meet the demand for suvs
partly detroit went in that direction
because once gasoline prices went down
then consumers so detroit had to make
these efficient cars
but consumers weren't buying them and
thus and of course the reason
trucks as they were called minivans suvs
had different fuel efficiency standards
because you know no one drove them in
the 70s unless you had a work reason for
driving them and then you know the
invention of the the appearance of the
soccer mom and
it became a whole you know and at one
point half the new vehicles
being sold were these kind of cars and
america's
love affair with the automobile turned
into a mad passion for the suv
uh but it was clearly connected to low
gasoline prices the
great you know the highest sales were at
the end of the 1990s when in
inflation adjusted terms uh gasoline was
cheaper than it actually ever been
so i think that um you know i think
people are on to it now
and i think that the fuel efficiency
standards have been rewritten have been
written such a way that they apply to
those as well so i think the whole
fleet's going to move in that direction
and i think i see detroit the ethos has
changed
and you can see the cars of the focus on
efficiency
now if everybody changes their mind and
don't care about it again
then you could kind of have another
crunch but it seems to me it's
more widely locked into kind of as
somebody says
in the quest the dna of thinking about
it
but that is detroit's fear is the
volatility on the part of the consumer
how do you see the end game for oil
playing out
and then what time frames if you could
even think that far by the end game
being as in like when we stopped we
stopped burning oil
to uh to transport us transport
ourselves around or
make energy well you know kind of
think out to 2030 once you get beyond
that it gets awfully hazy
i think that one picture would be
that we reach a kind of plateau sometime
around the middle of the century
and then we get what we get in the u.s
peak demand and decline we start to get
it on a
on a global basis if the electric car
uh other forms of transportation come on
more strongly and can
economically displace the automobile
that could happen more quickly
then you have a problem about how you
generate your electricity
but so i see it as a sort of
not a a sharp change but a long goodbye
is there anything on the horizon well
the uh defense department
uh is trying to create uh and i when you
talk about oil
are you you're not thinking you're
putting biofuels in a different category
right certainly the uh defense
department
is promoting uh and trying to develop
drop-in biofuels that would replace uh
jet fuel
and so that's an area in which a fair
amount of research is going on it
the secretary navy talks about a great
green fleet and that
wants to be half of uh the navy's energy
coming from
non-oil by 2020 which is a very
ambitious goal so
kind of one of the drivers there is the
defense department and also of course
they're just aware
these convoys where people get attacked
and so forth many of them are bringing
oil so it's uh are there other ways
kind of other ways to use energy so i
think you know
as so often happens that actually uh
defense military may be a major source
of innovation
i have in in the quest the story of how
churchill converted the british navy
royal navy from coal to oil specifically
to gain speed and flexibility against
the german fleet
and so i think i think that will be a
source
actually a source of innovation do you
discuss hydropower
i don't discuss it much i mean obviously
um
it's interesting if you look last year
about eight percent of u.s energy was
renewables
if you go back to 1985 about eight
percent was renewables
but it was a much larger segment of
hydropower i think it's quite
difficult to build large dams and so
it's kind of
low head hydro is you know but it it
doesn't seem to be a growth area i don't
know if you had a specific thought that
you
had it's one of these technologies
that's been around for a long time but
it's sort of not really considered
renewable the same way solar and and
wind are
uh yeah it would be it'd be very
difficult to build any large dam in the
united states and some would like to see
some of the dams
taken down so yes it's it's not
there was a period of great interest in
small hydro
but even that involves damming rivers
and so forth and so there's controversy
about it
for emerging markets what are your
thoughts around india's
energy needs and do you see renewable
sources like maybe solar
warmer climates being a way out or
how do you see them well it's
interesting one of the uh
innovators that i profile is an indian
wind tycoon
and he started the going into the wind
business basically because of the
shortage of
of electricity that factories were shut
down for five hours a day because they
didn't have power and here he could
offer a solution to people
so uh i think and
uh you know so a fair amount of interest
in
renewables in india and entrepreneurship
around it
and india does have these formidable
indian institutes of technology which
you know really turn out
first class talent so i i don't see the
same kind of
focused direction from the top that you
see in china but clearly a lot of
you know entrepreneurial energy going in
that and suzlan is one of the
major uh wind companies of the world and
it's its foundations are in india
whatever became of the hydrogen economy
i think you had a speaker here oh we
might have
didn't you uh did you have
jeremy rifkin no no
it was uh it's kind of one of those
things that's always out there
and uh you know i remember
in at one point we were gonna have a a
conference we do every year
in in houston we were going to have a
secretary of energy speak and he was
going to speak about
hydrogen and we just said you know you
might want to use the word long term
so it just before it so it always seems
to be out there
you mentioned your your fifth fuel being
efficiency
already seeing in the u.s sort of some
distortions and or
some real incentives from utility
companies
with their tariff setting because that
their demand is coming down
they're focusing much more on peak
shaving than they are on
reducing use and
along with that you're seeing some
consumer pushback or
uh ratepayer intervention resetting
innovation
interventions from people who don't like
the fact that so much more of their
base charge is just going to be to do
infrastructure recovery rather than the
variable cost recovery
it's it's almost a distortion like what
happened to the wire line phone
companies or that business just crumbled
pretty quickly i think it is a challenge
for utilities how do you turn
energy efficiency define it as an energy
source and then
make you know make it make money from it
how do you
design rates to do that there is a lot
of enthusiasm about smart grid
even you know until fairly recently but
then it turned out
that one of the ways that you would
you know you promote greater efficiency
was with variable rates
time of day and as it turns out a lot of
people don't like that they want to have
predictable rates
and uh certainly in the west there's
been some real rebellion against it
so you don't see quite the uh
excitement but the basic thing is that
it should be create a situation where
it's neutral for utilities uh whether
investing a new
generation or whether they're investing
in efficiency because
you get the same impact and i think in
general utilities would prefer not to
build
new capacity because it's expensive and
so forth
one thing we do see is that
you know oil demand may be going down
but at least in our view electricity
demand continues to go up
and one of the reasons is that you all
know servers and
and just the proliferation of gadgets
and
so we talk in the i talk in the quest
about gadget watts
and those need to be supplied because if
you go back to ronald reagan day
the amount of electricity used in the
home was pretty limited to
you know just a few different things and
today you know just think
all the things you have to keep charged
all the time
so i wonder when by the way i drove to
this beach
in a nissan leaf so tell us about it uh
it's fantastic
um and actually you know one of my
questions when you're talking
to the audio executives you know in the
pc industry there's something that we
call the
the osborne effect where osborne
computer
said hey just wait we're going to have
this fantastic computer and they went
out of business because everyone waited
for that next fantastic computer
and so i'm wondering if any of the audio
executives have an
answer for how do you keep talking about
these fantastic cars the electric cars
that are coming out and not
put people in a position where they say
well that would be great so
maybe i should just put off buying a car
right
by the way do the questions get picked
up for the
uh yes oh they do right good um
the um um
i think about the osborne effect
and so your question is that rather than
waiting for the
perfect car can you just ask the
question again well
yeah i mean if i were to expand it like
i have some people respond as i talk
about how
how fast and peppy this car is and how
many miles it gets and
how cheap it is to refuel it with
electricity recharge it
uh one of the things i've had people say
is well i'll wait till they have a
longer range
or all the way to a bigger vehicle
or you know there are lots of different
features that are important to people
and so you have two sides which is you
know one side is getting people on
to buying something that they've never
bought and they're not familiar with
and the other is discouraging people
from buying the product that you
currently make
which is of course a gas powered car so
you know i know there's kind of a
delicate balance between those two and
where you put your marketing dollars and
i i wondered if they had
certain well i think it varies from i
think all the companies
i mean not only i mean what's
interesting is you're getting a
positive consumer response i spoke the
other day at a
of all places an automotive museum in
los angeles and there's a guy there
who's actually in a business of
refurbishing corvettes
and he couldn't stop raving about a
chevy volt about how much he loved it
i thought god culturally very
interesting
so i think you are getting early
adapters early users
and that feedback i mean we're now in
that stage we'll
we'll feed back i find among the
automakers there's
a kind of range of views i talked to
carlos gone from
nissan renault and he is
you know he is gung-ho and feels this is
the future and uh
push push ahead on it uh i have
bill ford in the book though who says we
don't really know what the car
in 10 years is going to be so we have to
play on all fronts and the same with uh
daimler because i think the the general
thing you hear is that the cost of the
battery has to come down you still have
a car
whose price is you know you're not
really reflected
in it and there are a lot of you got a 7
tax credit etc so that's why i say we're
in this kind of
period but i think the feedback and
people you know
this person that person hearing what
you're going to say they're going to be
feel more comfortable uh thinking about
it too
and so we'll kind of see what the demand
is i mean hybrids
you know have been out now for uh 10
years and they're still a relatively
small
part of the mix i know some automobile
makers actually think the hybrid is
really truly the way to go
so i think it's still a testing period
but i think everybody in the room is
actually very interested in your
experience which it sounds like you
would describe it as
positive yeah very positive yeah what
made you decide to buy it
uh i'm an experimenter i mean i'm sure
everyone in this room were all gadget
crazy so i mean it's very much a
technology
gadget do you think about it yeah would
you have bought it without the tax
credit
absolutely and you think anybody else
would have
well it's relatively affordable i mean
it's not like the hydrogen cars that are
out there that are a million dollars
yeah or even a you know a tesla roadster
i mean it's a good deal more expensive
so
yeah well i think this is really
interesting i mean i think these are the
data points that uh
you know they're early adapters later
adapters but and it will partly depend
on what kind of the enthusiasm
i think that by the way if you don't
actually i mean the psychology of global
energy markets even if they're not
a lot of electric cars if they're enough
of them people are satisfied with them
that will start to change psychology
because what it will say is you have a
system that's not
primarily almost totally dependent upon
oil there are alternatives
then you'll get into the question of how
the electricity is produced and all
those
other questions but uh thank you for the
comment so
i think there and then we'll come to you
so if we if we decided that we needed to
walk away from nuclear
energy altogether i mean how far how far
away are we from being able to replace
all of our fossil fuel energy needs with
you know renewable energy i mean my
my question is can we really as a global
economy
say nuclear energy is too dangerous or
would well i think it's
able to get away well it's 20 of our
electricity it's about
30 of japanese electricity uh
i think it's uh it's obviously almost 80
percent of french electricity 77
so i think it's i think it is embedded
in the mix i by the way one of the other
great characters is a man who's probably
more responsible for nuclear energy than
anybody else in the book
uh admiral hyman rickover a few of you
will know his name
many won't but he was the father of the
nuclear navy and the father of nuclear
power
and it's you know you do look back on it
was actually done rather remarkably
quickly actually far quicker than people
thought would be possible
uh there's some interest in small
nuclear modular
plants as a kind of alternative where
they would be built almost
like in a factory and then rather than
having the kind of construction that you
do
now um at our last meeting this i'm on
the secretary of energy advisory board
that was a topic of of discussion
but we will face in a way your question
because
nuclear plants when they're first
established have a 40-year lifetime
then pretty clearly get a 20-year
extension
the next 20 but they get a heavily
upgraded in the course of that i mean
they're not
everything so many things get changed
the next 20 years then there starts to
be a
a question at least i hear people saying
about just will the economics work
to um retrofit them again
so that they can go 80 years so i think
in a way what you're raising is a
question that
will start to come on the agenda in the
next five or seven years
and i think renewables clearly are going
to
grow very important role but um
there's a gap that would have to be
filled
right here that was june um related to
that given the challenges
of the economics behind solar and wind
are there sustainable policies that
governments could implement to help us
at least
diversify our energy portfolio a little
bit more
i think everyone's aware of some of the
policies that have risen and squashed
but are do you have some
um thoughts about what policies might be
more effective i think that um
i have the i mean it was germany really
that's responsible for rebirth of the
of the renewable industry starting in
the 1990s
and there they did it with what are
called feed-in tariffs which kind of
blend the high cost of renewables
so they're blended to the overall
electric price and people don't really
see it and so
it gets the industry going we do two
things in this country one is the tax
incentives
uh which exist and uh we have different
the tax incentives that
jim delson was trying to get on that
tahati ridge in 1981 were
based upon just capacity uh but now it's
based upon how much electricity you
produce so
and then the other thing i think is very
significant is the
portfolio standards that the states have
and that really that is a huge driver
i mean jerry brown in california has
just signed a bill a couple months ago
saying that california will get
one-third of its electricity from
renewable
by 2020 very ambitious goal in a
particular state with 12 unemployment
but
nevertheless uh directionally it tells
you what's going to go so i think those
are the
kind of affected decisions that get made
and probably you know what's really
actually accelerated uh
wind and solar and
the idea is that the more you have you
you bring down the costs
so i think those are the kind of
policies i think in this era of fiscal
austerity
we're not going to see a lot of new
policies we'll see
entrenchment and one thing i worry about
is what happens to the basic
research and development budgets and
just maintaining their integrity
through this what might be a very
stringent period
well wait let me come around and then
um as the the cost for different
coaching
technologies out there you know mom can
go buy
solar panels from on the roof and
there's the fuel cell
as that becomes more cost effective when
do you
think that uh that type of energy source
will become a significant part of the
grid or will it ever is it just
well i think like i think wind is kind
of um
in the last few years before the
downturn
you know significant part of the new
capacity being put in was wind and so
wind is is is much larger than solar
i think solar is clearly grown a lot
it's a global business but just look at
the percentages it's still
very small and uh still it's a question
of
you know of getting the cost down
where these can compete without
subsidies and
incentives and uh but that's the name of
the
of the you know that's the name of the
game and i see it just so much on solars
it's all finding new ways to bring down
the costs
wind is a business it's already kind of
dominated by
you know the siemens and the general
electrics and the vestises so it's
already
be and of course there too you see the
chinese companies
you know the question they're clearly
global leaders in
solar now in production what their role
will be in the wind business is
something on the mind of everybody in
the wind business
do you see telepresence playing a big
role in the efficiency
fifth fuel uh
so that we don't have to travel right
yeah
probably yeah i uh
yeah i mean is that something you all
work on here and
so we had uh we had bomber at our
conference in march and uh
he certainly was demonstrating and
talking about it and
do you know of any data that exists on
its effect today
or i don't um
i don't um you you
somebody probably in the room does does
somebody work does anybody here have a
handle on that
like the potential impact of
telepresence on
reducing travel yeah like how many
people are watching this and we're all
stupid there's nothing yeah
absolutely yeah he's not going to share
with you
so what's your can you share your other
varnish thoughts on carbon
capture and storage yes carbon capture
and storage the notion is that
you capture the carbon one way or the
other out of a
out of a power plant
compress it transport it and bury it
somewhere
and you know you do the numbers
and you come to conclusion is that you
would it would be
as though you're creating a whole new
energy industry that works in reverse
that goes backwards
and the system we had is what is 150
years old or however you want to say so
uh and at least at this point
uh it's you know you don't have any
really significant demonstration
projects of it and the cost of it is
uh people send it by dad 75 percent
or 100 to cost so there are some people
you know clearly it's one of those
things people are working on and
committed to
and trying to make it work and at least
it may be part of the solution
but it's hard to imagine it on a huge
scale
and then the question is once you bury
the co2 who owns it who's responsible
for it
what happens if there's a leak and you
know you can as i'm on this commission
that we're
reporting to president obama on shale
gas and we know the controversy around
that
so so i think there's this whole other
the whole legal side of it is still
uh unclear so i guess would say
it's kind of part of the mix and people
will do it and some projects
may be built that way but we're far far
far from seeing it as something of large
scale to some extent
well i i don't know in chronology where
to put it but
you know as john deutch of mit says you
need a couple of
significant demonstration projects first
and we're not there yet and so that's
the kind of first gating item
that you have to get through
well thank you it's uh great to be here
i
enjoyed it thank you very much and
everybody who's viewing this and uh
uh you know if you offer i'll take you
up on a ride in your uh
in your leaf to the airport so thank you
very much and glad to be here with you
all
you